Narrator: BACK AT THE SHOP,
IT'S ALMOST BATH TIME.
Rachel: SO WE HAVE A PLAN.
WE HAVE THE POOL,
WE HAVE THE SCALE,
AND WE HAVE OUR LITTLE KLAUS.
SO THE FIRST THING
WE'RE GONNA DO
IS WE'RE GONNA
WEIGH HIM NORMALLY.
THEN WE'RE GONNA
GIVE HIM A BATH.
Narrator: GETTING HIS DRY WEIGHT
OF 19.4 POUNDS IS THE EASY PART.
NOW IT'S TIME TO GET WET.
OH, NO, NO, NO, NO!
NOT TOO HIGH. NOT TOO HIGH.
-OKAY.
-JUST RIGHT, RIGHT ON HIM.
RIGHT THERE.
-THERE WE GO.
Narrator:
WITH EIGHT DOGS AT HOME,
RACHEL'S GOT BATH TIME DOWN PAT.
-OHH!
-ELIJAH, NOT SO MUCH.
YEAH, I HAVE NO DOGS,
I'M A CAT PERSON.
WELL, I LIKE CATS. I'M NOT,
LIKE, I'M NOT A FURRY.
Narrator:
EVERY FIBER OF THIS FURRY FRAME
WANTS TO SHIMMY
FROM NOSE TO TAIL.
THE HARDEST PART WAS NOT GETTING
THE DOGS TO SHAKE.
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL THEY WANT TO
DO IS SHAKE.
ELIJAH GRABS A READING
OF 20.4 POUNDS.
NOT A SECOND TOO SOON.
THAT WAS ALL UP IN MY FACE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
Narrator:
THEN IT'S BACK ON THE SCALE
FOR THOSE VITAL
POST-SHAKE PARTICULARS.
TWENTY POINT ONE POUNDS.
YAY!
GOOD BOY, KLAUS.
Narrator: POINT THREE OF A POUND
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE MUCH,
BUT MATH GENIUS AND COLLEGE
SOPHOMORE CANNAN
SOON CONFIRMS THAT THE MYTH IS
OFF TO A PROMISING START.
THE RESULTS ARE THAT KLAUS LOST
ABOUT 60% OF HIS WATER WEIGHT
IN ONE SHAKE CYCLE.
Rachel: IT'S NOT 70%,
BUT IT'S STILL VERY IMPRESSIVE.
Narrator: IMPRESSIVE ENOUGH
FOR ELIJAH TO PROPOSE
HIS "PET" THEORY
OF COMPARATIVE SPECIES SHAKING.
WE'RE GONNA TEST TO SEE IF
HUMANS CAN SHAKE WATER
OUT OF THEIR HAIR,
JUST LIKE DOGS CAN
SHAKE WATER OUT OF THEIR FUR.
Narrator: NO PRIZES
FOR GUESSING WHICH HUMAN.
JUST LIKE KLAUS,
ELIJAH FIRST GETS WEIGHED DRY,
THEN IT'S DUNK TIME.
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
GO. DOWN.
THANK YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, THAT WAS FU-- [ LAUGHS ]
GO!
-OH.
Narrator: ELIJAH'S NOW WEIGHED
WITH HIS MANE RINGING WET.
AND THEN...
♪♪
OH, MY! WHOA!
[ CANNAN LAUGHS ]
ELIJAH.
E-ELIJAH.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: SO, LET'S GET THE DATA
ON DUDE VERSUS DOG.
Elijah: I GAINED 0.7 POUNDS
AFTER MY HAIR WAS SOAKED
AND I LOST 0.2 POUNDS WHEN I,
LIKE, SHOOK OUT MY HAIR.
OKAY. MATH MAN,
WHAT IS THAT IN PERCENTAGE?
THAT IS 28.5% OF THE WATER LOST.
Narrator: NOT TOO SHABBY.
STILL NO MATCH FOR KLAUS.
BUT TO GIVE THIS MYTH
A FAIR SHAKE,
THEY'LL NEED A MUCH BIGGER
SAMPLE SIZE.